- What's up, Netflix Geeked.
I'm Emily from the new
Netflix series, One Piece
and this is "Growing Up Geeked".
(exciting music)
I grew up on Dragon Ball Z.
I grew up on Pokémon, Yu-Gi-Oh!
I saw Spirited Away in
theaters when it came out here
in the States.
So all of the anime stuff, that
made me into who I am, 100%.
Sailor Moon, I made my parents
rent the Sailor Moon movie
all the time and they were so sick of it,
but I was just like,"Oh my gosh.
Women are so cool and so powerful
and they can do anything."
And it also just really
solidified anime in my life.
There are a lot of things
that I'm obsessed with.
I have been rereading One Piece
and then I have also been
watching Demon Slayer
'cause that's currently coming out.
Of course, so good.
And then I'm just constantly
on the hunt for more animes
that I haven't already seen.
I wish I hadn't gotten
rid of my Pokémon cards
and my Game Boy Color with all
of the original Pokémon Games.
I have beat myself up over that so much
because I'm like, "Why?
Why did I do that?"
That was amazing.
Like, I wanna play them now, you know?
I wanna have those cards now.
But, you know, live and learn, I guess.
It is so hard to choose one
TV show or movie or video game
because there's amalgamation
of all of those things
that changed my life.
Please make sure to check
out One Piece on Netflix.
You'll have to excuse them.
They're idiots.
- Oh, oh. (yells)
(atmospheric sounds)